huit ans après avoir reçu le prix
d'interprétation masculine pour the
artist jean dujardin revient sur la
croisette cette fois à la quinzaine des
réalisateurs dont il fait l'ouverture
avec le dain de quentin dupieux un film
étrange et jubilatoire comme souvent
avec ce cinéaste dans lequel son
personnage de français moyens va partir
dans une dérive criminelle à cause de
son buzz on a besoin évidemment qu'ils
appellent le dain ça va pour rien après
karam et des lépine qu'il doit faire un
irrésistible route d'entrepreneurs loser
en peignoir blanc et continue d'explorer
des univers singuliers du cinéma
français il est mon invité ce soir sur
canal + pour soir jean dujardin bonsoir
alors après le peignoir blanc
effectivement de et feel good way le
blouson en daim je me suis posé la
question qu'est ce que c'est un costume
pour l'acteur que vous êtes ce temps est
un camarade ce sera un soutien dans ce
cas là c'est un soutien oui c'est un
souci un soutien qui était qu'est venue
assez rapidement dès les essayages
d'ailleurs on en avait 4 5 dans la
garde-robe et ça a été le premier était
très évident il est à la fois trop court
plus vilain que les autres vous pouvez
pas dire c'était vraiment une espèce de
pot construit c'est un je pense que tu
as un essai en fait on n'a pas retrouvé
d'autres d'ailleurs donc il était très
évident qu est ce que le costume noeud
besoin d'un ici dit du personnage dans
le dos c'est pas tant besoin d'un mois
je pense qu'on aurait pu être
je sais pas une casquette un pantalon
une lampe
je pense que c'est un film qui ait fait
quel travail est fait par le vide où
chacun y met a priori ses névroses et
c'est sûrement ce qui m'a interpellé il
ya deux trois choses qui m'ont
interpellé quand j'ai rencontré quand le
lan vie de ce personnage de tout plaquer
l' envie de se barrer
le départ est un espèce de fantasme
masculin qu'on est assez récurrent
quand même même si la morale nous
l'interdît ou là où l'éducation où la
vie tout simplement
mais l' envie de se barrer ça c'est un
luxe qu'on peut se payer au cinéma et
puis de s'enfermer dans une chambre
d'hôtel et pourquoi pas qu'un blouson en
daim et de le faire parler
quand je vous dis ça aurait pu être un
fauteuil ça peut faire n'importe quoi
c'est un prétexte pour se parler c'est
un prétexte pour c'est une feinte de
routin ce film c'est un mec qui va
irrémédiablement dans le mur de toute
façon c'est que ça va pas forcément bien
se terminer mais vous ça a été un
prétexte pour vous parler avoue soro moi
je crois c'est le truc de mec seul qui
me font beaucoup rire chanteuse est déjà
même seringue hanifi
m'amuser à faire ça s'ouvre quand
j'avais des moments de solitude les mecs
qui avant de se coucher le mec ici qui
roule ses chaussettes le mec qui se
parlent au volant toutes ces choses de
mecs seul me sens beaucoup beaucoup rire
je crois qu'on s'est retrouvés avec
quentin sur ces espèces d'étrangeté de
la vie ces arythmies aussi dans les
dialogues c'est à dire que dès que ça
devient un peu trop justement qu à jour
le comedy trop évident il a une oreille
formidable ces réalisateurs qui résiste
à l'évidence beaucoup et tout de suite
il va dire non stop on arrête c'est de
la merde c'est de la merde c'est pas du
tout agressif ça veut dire qu'en gros ce
qu'on fait là moi mon cadre toi tous là
on est à côté on va revoir nos
prétentions et chez lui à côté c'est
justement mainstream c'est juste un oui
à côté c'est à côté c'est à côté c'est
l'incongruité de la vie il ya des choses
qui sont gênantes dans la vie hessa
hilal à l'échoppé vous savez si le
relais a été fait pour vous tailler sur
mesure pour vous non je crois pas non
non pas du tout je crois que c'est un
truc qu'il achetait en trois semaines on
va lui demander une fois de plus à mes
choix qu il ajouté très très vite et il
a pris du tout pensé à moi on imagine
comme ça nous en tant que spectateur un
tournage de copains du lieu comme un
lieu de recherche proche de l'atelier un
peu expérimentale
qu'en est il réellement est ce que c'est
c'est une méthode qui l'appliquent
il ya quelque chose de non
professionnels qui le préserve et il a
bien raison
je pense que c'est comme ça qu'ils se
distinguent c'est comme ça qu'il réussit
à voir sa petite boutique à lui ça veut
dire qu'en gros il ans ils ont ils
enlèvent pour le coup toute angoisse de
tournage ce qui est super agréable sakya
plus d'émissions on est trois dans une
pièce il ya l'ingé son lui et vous et
adel
quand elle est là elle est née je dormis
dernier l'ol c'est encore un autre
animal parce qu'elles se révèlent animal
au contact de georges
mais la méthode elle est très agréable
parce qu'on fait comme si on allait
jamais finalement
comme si ce film ne sortirait jamais on
regarde une scène t2a regard d'une scène
c'est la scène de votre première
rencontre avec le personnage interprété
par adèle haenel
on y va oui alors là c'est une position
un peu animal parce qu'en fait le
personnage vraiment en régression n'est
pas enfantine en régression animal sûr
que je me nourris georges e l'a pas un
ruisseau et puis j'essaie de survivants
mais là c'est pareil j'avais une
position rats on disait souvent position
bras alors je m'étais un peu en ra et
j'écoutais c'est aux nanas qui parle et
qui nous paraît absolument pas de moi
évidemment et je suis persuadé qu'elle
parle de mon blouson vous parlez
nombreuses on vous disait position rats
position rare comme ça comment marc a
quand même comme un mec est en planque
parce que c'est un mec qui est presque
en cavale il a agréé la montagne souvent
un hôtel et ce plan qu'elle en sait pas
trop s'il est où il va non c'est parce
qu'en fait on m'en parle tout le temps
quoi il faut des gens qui m'arrêtent
dans la rue je suis habitué à ce que ça
ça attire les agace pour ça ça devient
très identitaire pour lui ce blouson ça
que voilà je suis ce blouson que je suis
je suis là je suis le style de malades
c'est ce qu'ils disent j'ai un style de
malades qui vous dit quoi quentin
dupieux à ce moment là vous avez bien
que c'est pas il me dit rien et demi on
est d'accord en fait il dit
quand elle parle de ton blues ont enfin
été initié en parle parce je comprends
pas quoi qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pourquoi on parle pas de maison saint
gilles
je les payais 7000 euros merde l'étape
quoi il bute se compose en faut en
parler quoi et c'est ça que je dis est
ce qu'il vous dira mot western jean
dujardin du tout parce qu'on y pense
qu'on te regardes quoi il ya un truc
intérim est d'ailleurs en fait c'est non
parce que tout ça ce sont des éléments
qui se sont ajoutés au fur et à mesure
du projet c'est-à-dire en gros on ne
sait pas encore où on va tourner et puis
on à la région aquitaine et puis ça
s'est toujours bien d'avoir la région
aquitaine à ces super et puis on a les
montagnes et puis on a la vallée d'aspe
et l'alsace
c'est étrange avaler y'a pas grand monde
je vois qu'il ya deux mille habitants
sur 60 km c'est une terre déserte médias
qu'au même titre que le costume le
territoire a nourri le personnage
complètement il était fait pour rappel
il ya une séquence ou bojan terre des
blues au jazz ne veut rien dire et c'est
assez marrant mais mais mais c'est un
endroit qui est assez incroyable et
totalement fait pour le film c'est sûr
que c'est sale isole complètement et sa
vision de tous les méfaits qui peut les
tant mieux d'ailleurs
c'est vrai qu'à très peu de prises chez
cottin dupieux assez peu oui oui 2 3
c'est vrai qu'ils réclament un nouveau
jeu il réclama il voit la fabrication
immédiatement c'est à dire que si tu es
un peu fatigué était pas sur le coup tu
peux pas le berner quoi moi je crois
qu'en fait je ressemble beaucoup
beaucoup à quentin dupieux un seul et
comme souvent d'ailleurs on dit quentin
est un est un des fils de bertrand blier
je pense qu'il ya comme bertrand a pu
mettre un moment de verre dans le par
aux mouchoirs et lui a mis une barbe
avec une pipe c'est pas pour rien et
qu'à un moment on transpire le metteur
en scène quoi je ressemble à quand un
jeu par même comme content mais qu'est
ce que vous allez chercher chez lui chez
ce réalisateur aujourd'hui mais c'est
lui qui vient me chercher pour quelque
chose
moi je n'ai pas forcément pensé à
content mais le fait est qu'il est venu
et qui m'a proposé quelque chose et vous
arrêter oui j'accepte parce que je
laisse des places vides moi je laisse
déplace justement pouvoir des surprises
mais je n'ai pas de désir j'ai très peu
draguer les metteurs en scène j'étais
très heureux qui m'a projeté en
acceptant escape a aussi une forme
d'engagement non pas contre non pas en
réaction mais mais à côté de ces
comédies
un peu formaté quelque chose de l'or
dans un univers singulier allé
rechercher sa
le fait est qu il faille feel good je
trouve qu'il ya des dialogues qui sont
savoureux là il ya encore un univers qui
est complètement fou c'est vrai que je
m'ennuie assez rapidement la comédie low
cost me fait parfois un peu chier ça
veut pas dire qu'elle n'est pas de
qualité ça veut pas dire il certainement
pas d'ailleurs en voie fall play et elle
plaît aux parfois même au plus grand
nombre
je pourrais y aller je devrais y aller
j'y vais parfois mais mais mais pas tout
le temps j'ai envie de me faire des
secousses j'ai envie de me faire peur
j'ai envie d'avoir peur
au même titre que je viens de faire là
le polanski sur l' affaire dreyfus c'est
quelque chose que je redoutais je suis
content d'avoir ressenti quelque chose
de nouveau c'est exactement ce que je
recherche
mais ça depuis 15 ans en fait je le fais
la même chose depuis que j'ai fait le
convoyeur où brice de nice et le bruit
des glaçons vous citez évidemment
billets votre personnage rencontré son
concert wen forcément les parallèles sur
ici entre ces deux univers rendent
crédible et vivent ce genre de
situations absurdes
ça c'est aussi un défi je pense pour un
comédien oui mais pas mais en fait c'est
pas très compliqué c'est au même titre
que le cinéma muet ont dit oui c'est
difficile de jouer muet mais non tu as
juste aucune prise de son mais tu joue
de la même manière il suffit de quoi il
suffit d'y croire enfin messieurs jeudi
croit à croire à la situation mais quand
tu regardais les murnau city girl enfin
les premiers films des années 20 ce
n'est pas que de la pantomime où du
chaplin ça joue simplement
alors ça joue un peu plus mes applis
théâtrale message ou et sarsan de la
même manière que l'absurde si je veux
qu'ils passent je dois le ressentirez
jouait dans une normalité effrayante
j'ai je ne voulais certainement pas joué
la psychiatrie je voulais la jouer le
psychiatre je voulais l'approché la
ligne de craie l'approché de l'arbre oui
mais parce que la ligne alors je suis
bêtement dedans c'est qu'en fait il a
même pas de chute libre là c'est
carrément je suis passé de l'autre côté
dès le début du film mais ça me je pense
que c'est ça qui nous effraie dans ce
projet là c'est qu'en fait chacun on
peut le voir de deux manières où on
reste au large et on se marre et on se
dit c'est une bonne caudry se mobilisent
ou alors je suis effrayé parce que ce
que vit georges j'en suis pas loin c'est
ce qu'ils cherchent autant de
spectateurs voici ouais ouais bien sûr
au miroir ans est complètement sûr c'est
que je pense que ce qui me fait du bien
il vraiment cathartique il ya un truc ça
te permet de le je sais qui c'est
georges en fait franchement gens quand
on regarde la filmographie be
le loup scorsese tout récemment polanski
avec qui vous est juste de jouer
c'est extraordinaire qu'est doute rêve
de cinéaste j'ai jamais de rêve moi je
ne rêve pas je suis pas jamais non je
rêve je rêve
j'ai des rêves d'enfants qui persistent
dans la vie j'ai des sensations mais pas
dans ce métier je en fait que j'aime
dans ce métier c'est l'idée que je vais
vivre pendant 8 5 12 semaines l'idée
d'être un autre c'est un truc très
enfantin jeu s'explique comme ça
simplement c'est pas j'ai pas d'autres
rêvent que de que de ressentir une fois
de plus
alors si c'est avec des grands maîtres
si c'est avec des pointures c'est quand
même mieux
mais une fois de plus je les dragues pas
y viennent on en parle mais je peux
aussi me laisser le choix de dire non si
je sens que ça ne serait pas pour moi
justement les américains ont des goûts
avec hollywood on me l'a il n'a jamais
été question de layoule jamais en rien
je les ai toujours dit je vois je ne me
suis jamais retourné depuis des oscars
là bas sauf pour des petits trucs
s'il ya des franchement s'il ya deux
trois jours j'avais vécu cette histoire
avec scorsese les trois jours à brooklyn
c'était génial
moi ça me va très bien si je peux faire
quelques infidélités comme ça quelques
temps là bas mais surtout revenir ici
parce que vous rendez compte l'art en
trois ans j'ai eu la possibilité d'être
un abruti chez carlin délépine de faire
du mieux de faire le polanski jouer dans
ma langue
on a ainsi des mac et riche qui est plus
juste quand on s'appelle la question que
j'allais vous poser c'est quoi la suite
pour vous aux gens vous avez co réalisé
l exil de mouches un sketch des
infidèles ya sept ans après qu on en est
ou de ses désirs peut-être de mise en
scène non pas du tout non c'est bien je
pense que je serai vraiment un
réalisateur à ce titre à 55 ans je ferai
un genre de mec qui fera un film un film
ou deux que raptor arrangez vous pour
que la nuit du chasseur way où seront
sous la pluie quoi mais mais
mais sinon non c'est pas la réussite de
gilles lellouche par exemple qui est
votre ennemi d'un bep j -jc tej et
nature a été plus réalisateur que moi
ces jeunes cadets or vie non pas du tout
on nous demande beaucoup nous les
acteurs de réaliser j'ai pas grand chose
raconté je suis pas passionné par le
cadre c'est pas un truc qui me suis pas
pressé de voir une image
ce qui m'intéresse en revanche je suis
très client des acteurs je suis très
client des partenaires j'aime beaucoup
voir les gens jouer alors peut-être que
la mise en scène au théâtre
quelque chose comme ça pourrait
m'intéresser mais le cinéma jeu
franchement j'ai vraiment je n'ai pas
grand chose à raconter
alors vous avez annoncé jean le prochain
tournage du troisième volet c'est ce
sont 17
il serait écrit comme les deux premiers
par jean françois halin on sait qu'il va
le réaliser on sait on peut le dire fait
le dire non on va le savoir vraiment si
je pense que c'est un c'est un secret de
polichinelle je connais mais oui vous le
connaissez
oui mais on va mais non on voit préfère
de mystère là dessus mais qu'ils ont
mais on en parlera très vite un moment
vous avez hésité à reprendre ce
personnage vous disiez à cause de
l'ambiance qui règne en france ou est ce
qui vous inquiète pas forcément mieux
maintenant et c'est ça il ya cet
engagement là chez vous je me pose la
question parce que je trouve
effectivement à l'aspect satirique de
oss 117 qui des mots simples que le fond
réac suis certaine tradition française
je pense ifeelgoods aussi une charge
contre la start up nation
je pense à polanski dans j'accuse le
commandant picard celui qui a permis
d'innocenter dreyfus il ya ça aussi dans
votre choix de rôles c'est pas aussi
véhément c'est pas aussi poussée mais le
fait est que ça m'interpelle
le fait que je préfère parler de ça que
des problèmes de colocataires ou des
problèmes de cacau de quadras qu'on nous
propose quand même souvent dans les
comédies gel avantage d'avoir fait un
gagne fixé j'ai fait 4000 sketch sur la
vie quotidienne
donc je vous avoue quand on me dit ben
là c'est avec ta tante dans une cuisine
ça m'ennuie très vite j'ai envie il faut
être plus d'avoir à manger ou du moins
qui me raconte quelque chose
et qu'est ce que vous faites entre deux
films à je vis vraiment je suis un peu
en mode georges dont quentin dupieux
l'officier non mais pas loin d'en faire
qu'en fait alors mon plaisir c'est quand
je peux c'est courir un maximum et je
peux courir et courir avec de la musique
dans paris dans les villes et voir des
choses et voir des gens et regarder des
humains et pas trop réfléchir s'agirait
vachement bien faire des siestes
bouquiner pas trop m'arrêter le livre il
apprend du temps aussi
pas de film très peu et si on serait la
réalité le cinéma vous préférez la
réalité
je préfère complètement la réalité je me
sens vachement mieux depuis que je vis
bien la réalité mais vraiment mieux
cercueil j'ai bien compris que ce métier
ne prendra pas le pas sur ma vie je suis
plus heureux je suis plus heureux d'être
là avec vous je suis plus heureux de
vivre ma première journée à cannes parce
que je viens jamais parce que pas
souvent je fais jamais de festivals ou
deux mais pas par snobisme pas par part
est fait c'est juste que j'aime bien me
planquer bizarrement j'aime bien être
avec les miens bien être avec mes amis
d'enfance j'aime être dans ma vie j'ai
bien faire des choses simples canaux
tirer c'est la notion cgd et sensations
voilà merci d'être avec nous et merci
aux gars avec les joueurs dirigeants et
à bientôt le dain 2 comptant dupieux
vient d'être présenté en ouverture de la
quinzaine des réalisateurs et sera dans
les salles à partir du 19 juin on vous y
retrouvera jean tourret data lainelle et
d' albert delpy merci d'avoir regardé
cet entretien tout de suite la suite